mamma non mi disturbare chi inizia a
studiare le ragazze quando si truccano
iscriviti al canale per non perdere
neanche un video ciao io sono marina una
tv rowe e oggi ci trucchiamo insieme e
mi avete chiesto in tantissimi quale
fondotinta uso e uso questo adesso lo
applichiamo insieme e studio pix fluid
big mach mi piace molto perché ha un
finish mat quindi è effetto opaco ma
soprattutto a una lunga tenuta quindi
tipo non dovete ritoccarlo rimane
perfetto per tutto il giorno
make up perfetto manca solo lui il
miglior assetto preferito rubiu io sono
come le altre
io non ti lascio lì in un angolo
soltanto perché ora bisogna metterle
mascherina io ti voglio avere sempre con
me
sempre sulle mie labbra anche se gli
altri non ti possono vedere
[Musica]
andiamo come farci avere queste occhiaie
e che cos'è questo ieri non c'era male
che c'è il corretto
c'è veramente il mio migliore amico se
non ci fosse lui sa come fare sento già
meglio e non l'ho ancora stesso un'altra
persona oggi formulerò un nuovo prodotto
il miglior prodotto mai esistito
utilizzerò su tre ingredienti il
fondotinta studio pix l'illuminante e
una spruzzatina di brad più prime sticks
l'ass
ora mescoliamo quello che abbiamo
ottenuto è qualcosa di sensazionale è
qualcosa di meraviglioso
la scoperta del secolo quale metto mi
piacciono tutti e tre
come faccio a scegliere con calma marina
ce la puoi fare
analizziamoli 11 il mio rosso preferito
colore intenso lunga durata effetto
mangia mi sta benissimo
non c'è niente da dire ma qui c'è anche
qui chi ha lo stesso effetto di un
rossetto mat
ma con la morbidezza di un balsamo
labbra e poi guarda e perfettamente
abbinato al mio outfit
infine c'è lui
effetto satinato super nutriente grazie
all'olio d'argan ma guardo la mia
palette colori ci sembra fatto apposta
come faccio a scegliere potrei fare un
sondaggio si è anche bella idea
ragazzi ho bisogno di voi sono troppo
contento dei nuovi acquisti
guarda che meraviglia sei ore ad
osservare il pigmento i loro riflessi la
perfezione è questo qui sono così belli
che quasi mi dispiace utilizzati aspetto
qualche mese gli lascio lì li osservo li
ammiro
e intanto uso quelli vecchi e poi quando
sarò pronta utilizzano anche loro ma per
adesso adesso allora un bello ombretto
prugna tendente al nero come piace a me
ma comunque lo andrea scurire perché
comunque lo trovo una puntina chiaro
quindi nero a tanto amore
e dopo l'ombretto nero mascara nero non
esistono altri colori per me li mascara
cioè il mascara è nero il rossetto nero
mi sembrava troppo quindi oggi mi sono
concesso qualcosa di diverso ma pur
sempre e niente il tutorial definito
spero che vi sia piaciuto e fatemi
sapere nei commenti
a quale tipologia appartenete
iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino alla prescrizione per
non perdere neanche un video sia mio che
della new sicuro